it's weird I found this on that porch
when I got back from the theater and not
sure what it is but we are going to open
it right now so we'll find out what it
is keeping you all in suspense for a
long time here and it yeah it's exactly
what I thought it says Benicio del Toro
is cool again
good to know
Sicario the Sicario is the movie that
everyone's been blowing up my Twitter
feed really I said it's directed by the
director of prisoners and it's a very
gritty boots on the ground realistic
take on the war against the cartel this
movie we have Emily Blunt she's an FBI
agent she gets recruited by this group
as government faction who's going
against the cartel it's like maybe they
don't always play by the rulebook maybe
they bend the rules to get the job done
maybe you need to do that in a war like
this which causes tension between her
and them is ultimately that's the
premise of the movie getting right into
it first of all the movie is very well
directed it doesn't mean everything
meshed perfectly but I'm just saying
when the director was like I want this
to come across it did and the acting was
fantastic Emily Blunt just gets better
and better and better as her career goes
on I love seeing that I love being able
to say that I love seeing actors
progress and evolve I mean but Emily
Blunt when she first sprung on the
scenes Larry was the hot chicken that
werewolf movie now she's Emily Blunt no
one messed with that [ __ ] Josh Brolin
was great in his role in the movie he's
not what stands out though it is Emily
Blunt and Benicio del Toro
but ACO del Toro is by far the most
interesting character in this movie you
really don't know who he works for you
quite sure like is this guy on our side
he's a spook of some sort you don't know
what government he answers to you don't
know if he answers to a government he's
like Boba Fett oh you know for certain
is this dude's probably very good at
killing folks very tension-filled movie
very good at delivering that tension and
it's tension without a lot of explosive
payoff it's just tension like example
there's a scene where they're just
locked up in traffic and you know these
cartel guys are in cars around them but
you don't know where you don't know how
it's gonna go down you just know that
people who don't like each other are
kind of locked into a [ __ ] of
traffic not a good place to be you see
this movies going for the long haul it's
going for the deeper meaning behind the
war against the cartel in a realistic
way and in that this movie slows to a
crawl in many scenes there's no other
way around it there's no other way to
say it I start checking my watch I'm
like all right let's see some more on
cartel [ __ ] I get that the movies not
trying to go for that thing and has
succeeded what it's trying to do but I
can't deny that in many scenes in this
movie I was checking my watch because I
was bored it was a little jarring when
in the end of this movie the entire
climax of the movie didn't have to do
with Emily Blunt at all is all Benicio
del Toro story and it worked for me
because like I said Benicio Del Toro's
character was hands-down the most
interesting character in this
if they want to make a spin-off movie or
a prequel movie all about Benicio Del
Toro's character I'm down with that it
was a little jarring worse the entire
movie follows Emily Blunt and then in
the very end of the movies like all
Benicio del Toro is gonna wrap this
movie up imagine star wars and it
follows Luke Skywalker that's the
fish-out-of-water scenario just like
Emily Blunt in this movie we are
ultimately latching on to that character
as our eyes into this world and then
imagine in the end of Star Wars the
entire assault on the Death Star Luke is
nowhere in it it's all being led by Han
Solo a little jarring yeah and it was a
little jarring in this movie too now I
will say this in this movie and movies
like it I can grade movies like this on
one or two scales and it does create
some conflict within me it's like do i
grade and rate the movie as a work of
art a film that's well shot masterfully
crafted or do i grade and rate the movie
on entertainment factor like I usually
do I don't know what to say
entertainment factor replay value it
plays in the movies like this for me
I'll tell you if this movie is like zero
dark thirty meets traffic zero dark
thirty and traffic both very well made
films both well shot both well directed
both well executed well acted both
movies I have seen once and once only
never really had the urge to see again
in that this movie goes down the same
trail where it's like oh well acted well
directed beautifully shot holy [ __ ] the
tension I'm gonna see it again probably
not guys Sicario is well directed well
acted everyone in this movie kills it
they do a great job if I'm grading it
solely on that the quality of film as a
default in the movie delivers the thing
is how this is my channel and I'm going
to rate this movie up how I view this
movie I'm going to say Sicario is a very
good time a great time no alcohol
required right guys so Sicario have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more